joshua marine said challenges are what
make
life interesting and overcoming them is
what makes
life meaningful personal finance
folks is 80 behavior it's only 20
head knowledge the behaviors and the way
you operate your life
cause you to be able to build wealth
or not in spite of all
of the things that come against all of
us
is systemic racism real
absolutely
does it keep someone of a minority who
is a minority
from becoming wealthy no
we know this because there are
minorities who are wealthy that started
from nothing lots of them
lots and lots and lots of them
but extra hurdles to overcome
you bet absolutely
what are your options not
win and blame it on systemic racism
or when in spite of systemic racism
these are your two options
is do some people have a
an easier path than others depending on
their
upbringing
their education the area of the country
that they're born into which
country they're born into you bet
but you can find people who have built
wealth and
live a life of abundance from every
possible walk of life
starting from nothing there there
they just chose
to fight through the obstacles some
having more obstacles than others
there are legitimate obstacles out there
the pandemic has slapped some folks
around harder than others
legitimately
but the question you've got to ask
yourself is
what ten years from now is going to have
led me
to a life of abundance
is it a government program well the
historical answer is
no there's never been a government
program that led to abundance
of anything except in washington dc
but individuals out here in the real
world we don't
become wealthy and successful because of
government programs
stimulus checks fifteen dollar minimum
wage
socialist ideals we become successful
because of
our behaviors
we become successful because we choose
our
character to be that now does that
shame someone that hasn't become
successful no it just tells
someone that hasn't yet become
successful how to do it
and it's not sitting on your thumb
waiting on a stimulus check
it's not sitting on your thumb waiting
on aoc
or biden or trump or anyone else to fix
your freaking life
there is not an answer to your problem
that's going to come out of washington
the sooner you take responsibility the
better you off you are
and that's not to say that where you are
is your fault
it is to say that where you're going is
your fault
and your beliefs cause your
behaviors and if you believe
the government is going to fix or some
person
or some movement or crusade is going to
fix
the barriers that are in your life
you're wrong
and if you believe that you're gonna sit
and wait on someone else to fix your
life
and it's never gonna get fixed
it is up to you
so i started from nothing when i came
out of college
and i started buying and selling real
estate and i became
wealthy at least by a kid from my
neighborhood standards i had four
million dollars worth of real estate
made two hundred thousand dollars a year
back in the ninth early nineteen
eighties
and that's back when two hundred
thousand dollars was a lot of money
i did a lot of stupid things like borrow
too much money like borrow it on short
term notes
and our bank got sold to another bank
and they called our notes and we spent
the next two and a half years of our
life
losing everything we owned some
of what caused that were changes in the
banking laws that encouraged and allowed
the banks to do that to me
and for a while i sat around and blamed
the meno bank and i blamed the irs
and i blamed ronald reagan for changing
the laws and banking that affected the
snls
and caused the snl crisis by the way the
destruction of an entire section of the
banking industry
i blamed everyone else
and i sat there for a while getting
absolutely no traction
and not recovering at all
from my losses and i just sat on my
thumb
and whined about everybody else picking
on poor old dave
but the revelation came along that if
you're gonna have that many lemons you
might as well make some lemonade
and a good friend said you need to stop
your whining you want some cheese with
that wine
and you need to get up off your butt and
go fix this and oh by the way figure out
what you learned
from all this pain what'd you learn
what'd you do wrong that you'll never do
again figure out what you're never
against are because of this
and so i started studying rich people
not broke finance professors with a
theory
how'd they get rich where'd their money
come from and how did they get it
and i was a baby christian and i started
studying the bible and what it has to
say about money
and both those sets of principles lined
up they're called common sense
get out of debt live on less than you
make
work like a maniac and create income
there's a great place to go when you're
broke my grandmother said to work
it will change everything when you do
that
everything and so when pandemics come
bankruptcies come when 2008 comes or 9
11 comes
when racism comes
or wealth inequality comes or someone
treats you poorly because you have a
southern accent or northern accent
or you have a college degree or you
don't or you have student loans or you
don't
whatever your mountain is that you have
to climb and you have a mountain you
have to climb
are taller than others
but you've got to climb the mountain so
you need to sit down and say you know
what have i done wrong so far
what are the lies that i believe about
life
that are holding me back and what am i
going to change
a lot of the things i believe came from
the neighborhood i grew up in
and a lot of the lies i had to lay down
and never again believe
came from the neighborhood i grew up in
some of the best qualities came out of
the household i grew up in
and some of the lies that i had to lay
down came out of the household i grew up
in and that's true of every one of us
every one of us so growing up
is setting down the lies and embracing
the truth
and hustle and grind get up and leave
the cave and kill something and drag it
home
if you believe someone is coming to your
rescue
you're screwed because no one is
it's up to you baby doll suck it up
buttercup
you got this you can do it i know
you can do it because i've watched tens
of millions of you
do it lay down the lies
pick up new beliefs embrace new
behaviors
and change your freaking life don't wait
on the government to do that for god's
sakes